Hello and welcome to
YouTube Behind the Scenes.
My name is Mat’as Molinas
and I am a Google Developer
Expert for YouTube APIs.
Today I am going
to introduce you
to the YouTube Data API.
This API allows you to
use all the operations
that are available
on the YouTube website
from your YouTube account,
by using this application.
For example,
with the Data API
you will be able
to manage your playlists,
upload videos,
and use the search engine.
In order to do this,
there are client libraries
available in the majority
of programming languages.
Whatever programming language
you decide on,
a client library
probably already exists
and you will be able to use
the Data API.
In any case,
to make today's lesson
easier and faster,
the code examples we will see
will be shown in
JavaScript and HTML,
so you can use the text editor
of your choice,
such as Notepad++.
If you know how to use
the Google APP Engine,
or if you have
Eclipse installed,
you will be able to work
with this
and display you application
on Google servers.
In this lesson we will look at
the following subjects:
how to register your application
and implement OAuth 2.0,
how to upload a video to YouTube,
and explain YouTube's
new Universal Search
and its Freebase integration.
Are you ready?
Let's begin!
ÀHOW DO YOU REGISTER YOUR APP
AND IMPLEMENT AOuth 2.0?
So that your application
operations
can create, actualize,
and eliminate items
from YouTube,
such as videos and playlists,
you must authenticate the user
and this should
authorize your application.
To do this, the YouTube Data API
uses OAuth 2.0,
so we will see how we can
configure OAuth 2.0
to use the YouTube Data API
from web client applications
on the server
and applications
installed on devices.
We will see which steps
are necessary
to configure OAuth 2.0
for your application.
STEP 1
CREATE A PROJECT ON GOOGLE
In order to use
the YouTube Data API
from your application,
you need to register
your project on Google.
Let's see how to do this
from the Google Console.
Go to the Google Cloud Console
through the following
web address.
Select a project,
or create a new one.
Select "APIs & auth"
on the menu on the left
and confirm that the status
for YouTube Data API v3 is on.
If not, select "ON."
ENTER YOUR APPLICATION
INFORMATION
Calls to the YouTube Data API
require an API Key
and an OAuth 2.0 Token.
The Browser Key
and Server Key sections
show your application keys.
Us the Browser Key
with applications
that need the API
to access public information
from the browser.
And the Server Key
for applications that need
the YouTube Data API
to access public information
if your application
runs on a server.
If you expand
the OAuth 2.0 Client ID section
you will find the Client ID
and Client Secret
that you will use
in Redirect URI
in your application to obtain
an Access Token.
To access private
user information,
your application will need
to send this Access Token
with every call
to the YouTube Data API.
STEP 2
PERMITS
For the user to use
the YouTube Data API functions
from your application,
the user must have
opened a session
with their Google
or YouTube account,
and must have gone through
the authorization process
with OAuth 2.0.
In this step
we will specify
what permits or Scopes
our application will require
to manage operations
in the user's YouTube account.
After the user approves it,
we will redirect it
to a Google
authorization server.
They will be asked
to select their account
and approve the permits
the application asks for.
STEP 3
USER SESSION
When the user ends the session,
your application will revoke
the Access Token.
HOW TO UPLOAD A VIDEO
TO YOUTUBE
Uploading videos from
your application is a function
that allows the users
of your application
to create content.
An example of this function
is allowing the users
to create videos
about how to use
your application.
For example,
if it's about a game,
how to play a certain part.
Two of the most
well-known cases of games
on YouTube that allow
their users to create videos
are FIFA 13 and Talking Tom.
With FIFA 13,
users can repeat the game,
and if they want,
they can upload it as a video
on YouTube
and share it with their friends.
These videos will allow
a user community to be created
that share content
from your application on YouTube
and that will promote
your application through videos
on social networks.
These videos will be cataloged
by YouTube
and this will allow new users
to find your application
when they use
the YouTube search engine.
They will also find it
through videos.
How do we do that?
There are three strategies
for capturing and uploading videos
from cell phones:
Local Capture, Cloud Capture
and Hybrid.
The Local Capture strategy
consists in creating the video
on your cell phone application
and then directly uploading it
from your application
to the YouTube Backend.
For the Cloud Capture strategy,
what you do is send the
parameters of the game,
or the scene, to the backend
of your application,
which creates a video
from these parameters
sent from your cell phone
that can be uploaded to YouTube.
Finally,
the Hybrid strategy
is an alternative
where your application
creates certain resources,
such as images and sounds,
on your cell phone, and then
sends them to a cloud server
that creates the video
and then uploads it to YouTube.
Let's look at an example of code
that shows how to upload
a video to YouTube
from a Java Console
application.
This example can be
the basis for implementing
any of the 3 scenarios
or strategies we analyze
once we already have the video.
STEP 1
THE YOUTUBE SERVICE
You must have an Access Token
that has at least one
of the following Scopes
approved.
And with this Access Token,
you will create
a service application
that will provide you with calls
to the YouTube Data API.
STEP 2
SEO DETAILS
You will need to define
the video metadata.
It is very important that
it be configured correctly,
since this determines how
it will be cataloged on YouTube,
and in which search results
it will appear.
Apply everything you know
about SEO
to choose the title,
the description, and the Tags.
Correctly selecting
these parameters
will make it more likely
for your video to appear
within the first few
search results.
STEP 3
INSERT
Finally, insert or upload
the video to YouTube
using the YouTube Data API.
Let's see how the code
would be to complete this step.
WE INSERT THE VIDEO HERE
We have just seen how to upload
a video to YouTube,
in this case
from a Java Console application,
but there are client libraries
for most programming languages,
and we can use the service
from desktop, cell phone
and server applications.
YOUTUBE UNIVERSAL SEARCH
AND ITS KNOWLEDGE GRAPH
INTEGRATION
One difference between
YouTube Data API version 3
and version 2,
is its Freebase integration,
or the Knowledge Graph
Google uses
in its searches.
Knowledge Graph integration
allows us to obtain results
not only including
resources that correspond
to the key words
used in the search,
but also items related
to our search.
A simple way to understand
how a search using key words
through the Knowledge Graph
is by searching for
"Leonardo da Vinci" on Google.
By doing this,
we see the results
in the column on the left
correspond to documents
that include
they key word
"Leonardo da Vinci,"
but the results on the right
are images and information
about items related to
the "Leonardo da Vinci" item
in the Knowledge Graph.
For example,
among the related items
we find the Mona Lisa,
which does not include the key
words "Leonardo da Vinci,"
but it is a related item.
This gives us
much more interesting
and educational search results.
In this way,
we can take advantage
of this Knowledge Graph
integration
through the Universal Search
YouTube Data API.
Why do we call it
a Universal Search?
Because the results can include
different types of resources,
such as channels, playlists,
or videos,
all in the same search.
Another advantage
is that the results are
shown by relevance
on the server side.
Let's look at some real examples
that use this technology
to see the power of APIs
and how they can create
a pleasurable user experience.
THESE ARE EXAMPLES THAT UPLOAD
VIDEOS WITH THE API
HERE THE API IS USED TO SEARCH
How can you take advantage
of all this?
Let's see how you
can obtain information
from Freebase items
and YouTube video items
and then use the IDs
from these Freebase items
in the search.
STEP 1
YOUTUBE TOPIC EXPLORER
In this example
we will see part of how
Open Source YouTube Topic
Explorer application functions.
This application uses
the playlists that YouTube uses
to save user activity information
to then recommend content.
These lists are
uploaded videos, favorites,
videos where the user
put "like",
and videos they want to see
later on.
It's also worth mentioning
that all YouTube user accounts
have a related channel,
which we can use,
with user authorization,
to consult these lists,
and obtain these videos
and their metadata
to obtain the IDs
of related Freebase items.
Yes, YouTube videos now have,
along with their metadata,
Freebase item IDs
automatically assigned to them
by YouTube.
Let's see how we can obtain
this information
and then organize
the Freebase items
related to the videos from these
user lists by relevance.
OBTAIN USER PREFERENCES
OBTAIN FREEBASE INFORMATION
ORGANIZE BY RELEVANCE
OBTAIN NAMES FROM FREEBASE
STEP 2
THE UNIVERSAL SEARCH
Once we have selected
and introduced
the Freebase items
related to the collection
of user interest,
how can we use
the Universal Search
to obtain resources
related to one of these items?
Let's look at the code.
SEARCH FOR VIDEOS RELATED TO
A FREEBASE ITEM
SEARCH PARAMETERS
THESE VIDEOS
ARE THE SEARCH RESULTS
LET'S DO AN EXERCISE!
Did you know that the Data API
also allows you to access
Activities, which are resources
that allow you to obtain
information about an action
on a channel or from a user?
For example, they allow you
to obtain the recommendations
presented
on a YouTube user Home Page.
How would you use
these recommendations
to obtain related
Freebase items?
SOLUTION
WE OBTAIN THE ACTIVITIES
FROM THE YOUTUBE
USER HOME PAGE
ONLY USE
THE RECOMMENDATIONS
LET'S DO ANOTHER EXERCISE!
And how would you get
the same information,
but now from the social
activities related to a video?
SOLUTION
USER SOCIAL ACTIVITIES
ARE USED HERE
I hope that you enjoyed
this lesson.
We have learned how to use
the Data API
from an application
to upload and search for videos.
We have also learned how to
register your application
and use OAuth 2.0
in order to use
all these operations.
To do this,
we used, as an example,
code from the YouTube
Topic Explorer application.
I recommend you analyze it
in detail.
It's an excellent example
of how to use
the YouTube Data API,
and also how to make
an application
with JavaScript using
AngularJS.
I invite you to watch
the next lesson,
where we will see, in detail,
how we can use the Data API
to manage and optimize
your YouTube channel.
See you in the next lesson!